für die Laufsteg Bucht werden oder das
Gesicht von der grossen Marke Ark fragt
werden modeln ist ja so ein Traum von so
vielen
jungen
andere verlockende
gleich geschrieben so ja ob ich mit ein
paar Millionäre auf einer Yacht will und
da halt dafür bezahlt werde
das klingt jetzt nicht wie ein Model Job
exklusive Partys und luxuriöse Events
für viel Geld behindert
die Männer mit eindeutiger Absichten ja
Menschen sich sehr dass man einfach mit
der Models verschlafen dann hast du
irgendwie innerhalb von einem Abend
irgendwie so ein paar tausend Euro
einfach so sich sich in verrückt die
Welt
der Recherche des Grenze zwischen
seriöser Jobs und der Prostitution für
Models nicht immer klar ist
wie komme ich überhaupt auf das Thema
letzte Sommer hätten wir das Model wann
ich selber persönlich kenne von der
Problematik von der Schatte sieht der
wie sie es genannt hat vor der
Modelbranche verzählt konkret ganz darum
dass sie immer wieder so bezahlt die
Angebote für Ferien irgendwo im Ausland
bechami vordergründung sexuelle
Handlungen
verkauft soweit also ihre Erzählung
gerade weil ich vorher noch nie
ich kontaktiere immer den ersten Schritt
15 Models wo die Schweiz sind und frage
sie ob sie auch schon mal für Service
oder gar nicht vor dem Wissen dass das
überhaupt geht ein Großteil ist sich dem
Phänomen ist sich dem bewusst hätte
schon mal so Anfragen bekommen ja immer
nur regelmäßig und was das für die sind
wird die gerade mal schnell vor lassen
ich hatte das wieder spezifisches
Angebot hey how are you we are
organizing a pay trip the creator doing
the mans of joy and August the dates are
und damit zur Vorschlag von ihr bis 8
Tag lustig noch an einem Datum statt
spezifisch Black Eyed Peas weekend
concert on the yacht und generell also
es wird verflügzahlt es wird für das
erste Zeit und für Unterkunft und man
wird zusätzlich noch
zahlt also 2000 Euro auch noch
wie andere Angebote
hatte statt zwischen 1.500 bis 2000 pro
Tag also sich viel Geld und ganz ehrlich
dass der Joe [ __ ] verlockend
so viel Geld aber für ich meine macht
Ferien
aber man weiß natürlich nicht was genau
hinter so Angebot steckt mich nimmt
Wunder was sind das für Lied wo der
Models so Jobangebot schicken ich
bekomme 6 Instagram Profil
zurückgeschickt alles gut aussehen die
junge Männer und ICE Facebook Profil von
einer Frau ich schriebe alle a und wird
wissen was das eigentlich für das
Business ist und was hinter deiner
Anfrage genau steckt was ich nämlich
komisch finde dass man Geiges Honorar
für verivari zieht Gesellschaft leistet
nennt man eigentlich Escort wo er Form
von der Prostitution ist da in einer
Nachrichten wird aber vor Image Jobs
gerettet und Escort und Sex explizit
ausgeschlossen im Internet finde ich
auch nicht wirklich viel über die Image
Model Jobs das einzige wo ich zum Thema
finde sind das Paar Pflicht von der Jazz
Egger sie hat schon vor fünf Jahren in
Englisch und amerikanische Medien über
ihre Erfahrungen mit der Thematik
auspackt
bis jetzt alle Models von jag gefragt
und aus internationales Model ist sie
tätig sind immer wieder versucht auf
Problem wo ihre Modelbranche wieder
Fahrer sind aufmerksam zu machen wie zum
Beispiel mit ihrer Aktion Hashtag truez
behind the shot wo sie aufzeigt wie Fake
die ganze Bilder auf Instagram sind
jetzt knapp zwei Jahre später seit sie
versuchen sie die ganze Machenschaften
mit dem Image modeling aus Licht bringen
und schrieb über das jetzt das Buch
so jetzt bin ich gerade in Innsbruck und
triefer Jazz jetzt
muss ich vor fünf Jahren in London
geschaffen hat hat sie ihr Nachricht mit
der Afra für
das hat sie dann sofort öffentlich
gemacht auch citarrezinieren
und über Nacht ist das dann halt
komplett explodiert und habe halt dann
sehr viele Anfragen bekommen von allen
möglichen Magazinen und Fernsehsendern
Radiosendern auf der ganzen Welt und da
ist mir erst bewusst geworden wie heftig
das eigentlich alles ist weil man eines
Abends aus in einem Club habe da viele
neue Leute kennengelernt und dann hat
einer gesagt cool du bist nur an der
Stadt ich habe immer ganz viele Jobs für
Models ich soll Ihnen meine Nummer geben
so cool ich erst 18-jährige
und am nächsten Tag hat er mir gleich
geschrieben so ja ob ich mit ein paar
Millionäre auf einer Yacht will und da
halt dafür bezahlt werde
das klingt jetzt nicht wie ein Modeljob
ist dann gleich so Nähe also ich bin
eher so ein klassischen Modeljobs
interessiert habe dann abgelehnt und
dann ja später habe ich eine
whatsapp-nachricht bekommen von der
fremden Nummer aber das war dann
ziemlich krass weil ich habe dann
gelesen und dann stand da ja heute abend
Dinner mit einem bekannten Schauspieler
2000 UK pounds
und ich noch okay das klingt jetzt schon
mal ein bisschen sketchi was ist da
jetzt los und dann habe ich weiter
gelesen dann stand da maski okay with
following in timiso oder irgend sowas in
die Richtung so krass okay ähm ich dann
gleich zurückgeschrieben sorry ich bin
Model und kein Escort er hat mich dann
bombardiert mit Nachrichten habe mich
versucht zu überzeugen dass das
normalste ist überhaupt das ist die
ganzen großen Models machen und die
bekannten Schauspieler da involviert
sind und whatever
hat mir Screenshots geschickt also
wirklich um das zu beweisen da hat dann
auch gesagt
ich werde es nie zu irgendwas schaffen
mit meiner Einstellung wenn ich das wenn
ich das so nicht mache das bleibt mir
bis heute im Kopf wieso denkst du packt
da niemand darüber aus das Problem ist
dass wenn man
Teil der Industrie ist und dann sich
gegen die Industrie ausspricht
weil die so viel Macht haben machen die
schon so dass du dann irgendwie
rausgeschoben wirst
Beispiel ich habe viele Agentur Verträge
verloren deswegen haben gesagt nee also
was wenn du mal was über uns sagst dass
er da dann sage ich halt ja wenn ihr
nichts irgendwie zu verbergen habt dann
braucht ihr auch keine Angst deswegen
haben aber ja viele Agentur Verträge
verloren wenn ein Model das 100%ig
sozusagen
möchte und okay mit dem ist wo ist dann
das Problem so ganz ganz hart gefragt
das ist überhaupt vorgeschlagen wird das
ist eine Option ist und dass es
innerhalb einer professionellen
Atmosphäre geschieht und das soll halt
einfach nicht böse absolut nicht okay
tschüss tschüss
Jazz verzählt ist es klar dass es
Statements regelmäßig eine verzählt
also
[Applaus]
so Sachen
von der Prostitution anders als beim
escorting ist der zitrum aber länger
gehabt wird klar sind Anfrage für
Service
ersichtlich um was es geht und man kann
das Frau oder Model die Jobs einfach
ignorieren oder ablehnen wenn man das
nicht wollt extremste Beispiel
zugeschickt bekommen es ist es Casting
für das Saudi Trip Party sie Frage für 5
vettele und das Video im Bikini wo man
auch noch posieren der Preis sag jetzt
die Pens on your beauty wird auf maximal
24,7 plus image
extra und extra heißt sie der sprach so
viel wird also mit deiner Typen muss
schlafen also es ist ganz klar um was es
da geht problematisch wird es denn wenn
ich deine e-ladigung Jobangebot nicht
klar ersichtlich ist
normal ein anderer Anruf es wird das
Model verzeiht mir genau so
undurchsichtige Angebot sie hat in
la-grund und ihre Mitbewohnerinnen sind
tatsächlich auf so Angebote
[Applaus]
meistens
unsere Teams sowieso gerade
sollten sich
schutzen
das macht für 50.000 Franken hat sie
abgelehnt aber das ist nur mit dem zu
nachtselblieben oder alles nur Party und
Ferien ist für so extrem für Geld das
ist miner meine Nacht ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich das zeigt man auch noch
Model innerer Nachrichten Rebecca ihren
Namen
die anonym bleiben
Vermittler rebecca ist international
vieler Castings unterwegs und was sie da
erlaubt wird sie mir verzählen zum IDE
Anonymität Ware ihre stimmenaussprache
was passiert ist das modelshalter ihre
Castings
sogenannte promoters wurde halt Models
rekrutieren oder sie aussprechen für
sozusagen
also von Anfang ab plane zeigen so mit
einer coolen Zeit lockert genau ja
das ist einfach absurd dass man hat zwar
wienes Objekt wird
und auch lieber
zeigen
ist agenture im Ausland vor allem die
Tür bewusst Models Ausnutzen der befüllt
wenig lohnen viel Spaß
komplett normal dass man aus Model bis
zu meiner Jahr später oder bis zu gar
nicht gezahlt wird und auch um Halt
und hat zum Wohnen also Agenturen Sorge
dass man es Model Apartment hat aber die
sind komplett über Türen
und das ist es Riesenproblem man muss
den wie andere Job haben
dass du vielleicht auf dumme Ideen
stecke die war die schamlos von der
Promoter ausgenutzt ganz am Anfang von
der Reportage Anja
Jobangebote Modus geschickt hat wie sich
jetzt ausgestellt hat sind es aber
genauso Promoter wie mit Rebecca
verzählt hat vor zwei Jahren Antwort
bekommen der eine Seite zwar mit Partys
aber er war dann immer oben draufzahlt
dass er Girls da mitbringt und der
andere da weiß Jeans von garniten also
auf dem Weg komme ich nicht wirklich
Armee Informationen in dem Moment
erreichen wir es Mail von meinem Model
in New York sie hat gehört dass ich an
der Reportage schaffe und möchte sich
zum Thema äußere vs wichtig findet brana
ist ambasadorin von der unabhängigen
Organisation wo sich für Tracht vom
Models i setzt für Sie 6 okay wenn eine
Frau systemwelle Sexualität abbietet das
Problem Sigi aber folgendes
get report it are of this nature of this
Prostitution problem in the model
Industrie I don
Agenturen
und ihre models for the jobs schützen
mich passiert ob Schweizer Modelagentur
vor dem Wissen und wie Sie mit dem
umgönnt ich schriebe 5 Modelagenturen an
und bekomme vor zwei Jahren die
ein-agentur schreibt sie informiere und
warne ihre Models vor so Angebot im
Ausland und sorge dafür dass alle Jobs
und Shootings vor seriöser Firma
aboverdi mit der Antrag direkt reden ich
triefe der headbucker von der grössten
Modelagentur von der Schweiz der Peter
Kuen sucht einerseits neue Gesichter und
andererseits Jobs für Sie bestehende
Models und ist seit über 25 Jahre im
Modelbusiness
im Rahmen von der Reportage wir verzählt
sind ist das Model Air quillt ist
sondern das Angebot
arzneiweltagenturen Sport Zahlen nicht
zahlen wenig aufmerksam machen sorry
ist ein Aufbau von meinem Job wie jeden
andere wenn ich Lehrgang verdiene 500
Franken deswegen nicht automatisch
unseriöse Angebote und das Agenturen
sportzahlen es gibt einzelne Agenturen
die sind Schlitzohren die sind aber auf
vorher schon bekannt dass man Leute hier
am Frankenberg sehen
wie jetzt Social Media
allgemein mit Internet der Mensch ist
hemmungslos worden auf dem Internet und
getraut sich die wildeste Sache zu
fragen jetzt kommentiere oder
verschicken und dementsprechend sobald
du natürlich einen schönen Instagram
Account hast und einigermaßen
schön überreichwunsch kann man natürlich
auch die ganze komische Angebote den die
kennt jeder auch im privaten Bereich das
betrifft nicht nur Models das ist leider
Gottes es Phänomen wo heutzutage normal
ist also über ihr Wissen dem Fall oder
dir übrig bekannt vor deiner Angebot für
deine Zielrichtung Models oder auch
influencerinnen
ich glaube das kriegt man Freude später
meistens auf deinen Accounts in der
blockiert man das einfach und fertig
haben mehrere Angebote was Model Sau
geschickt bekommen und das sind Angebot
zum Beispiel für eure exklusive
yachtparty für acht Tage irgendwo in
Kroatien
ich glaube das bewegt sich eher richtig
Influenza oder ich sage jetzt mal böse
wannabetes
trotzdem versuchen irgendwie
konkret noch gesagt da würde ich mir die
nie Antworten zu aber wir wundern dass
sich Model und Prostitution durch Social
Media immer mehr nein nein nein da wäre
es mir aufs heftigste Inneres Gegenteil
in das Gegenteil dieses Business
setzen nein nein der Peter appelliere
Social Media Accounts
mit Rebecca und alle anderen Models
verzählt hat die nämlich trotzdem ernst
und die kann man gut vorstellen dass sie
dem kompetitiven Model Business hat
danke
am Schluss vor der Reportage treffen
jetzt mit Manuela frei die 25 Jahre
Aargauerin hat die letzten 8 Jahre in
New York gelebt und das Model
international schon viel Erfahrung
sammelt ich hole sie vom Flughafen ab
und möchte Dir Sachen wo ich auch
gefunden mit ihrer besprache der Agentur
sie sagen
plus sechs vor allem das Problem für
Social Media wechselstudio
will ich meine
andere Sachen oder
[Musik]
spricht sich alles so schnell um sich
sehr schnell
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Agentur und jetzt hat Manuela Fräser
beides
einfach nicht mit dem seriöser
Modelbusiness stuehend ich danke einfach
dass es so und Jobs immer genau
ist nicht klar ersichtlich das Zusatz
sich zum präsent sie nur mehr kann
erwartet werden wenn man sich aber aus
freien Willen und mit dem wissen auf was
man sich da genau das macht den ist für
mich kein Problem was mich jetzt aber am
Schluss vor der Reportage wirklich noch
nervt ist wir verschwiegert dass das
ganze nicht also kann ich zusätzlich
auch noch
dahinter steckt oder mit der Rede wo
sich schon mal auf seines Angebot eh
Klarheit darum wenn Du mehr weißt oder
du dich vielleicht schon mal auf seines
Angebots
ist abonniere doch gerade der Kanal da
SRF dog auf YouTube